hi I'm Lani puto and I'm Katherine echo
and this is Dragon Ball Z a bridge
behind the scene episode 3 the finale
the Seine and Frieza sagas made up the
first two seasons and five years of team
four stars Dragon Ball Z abridged series
during which they transformed the quaint
online parody show to a fully fledged
comedy production viewed by literally
tens of millions of people per episode
with drastically improved voice acting
editing and writing across the board
their little series quickly elevated to
never-before-seen Heights once episode
30s climax graced our screens however
perhaps the most impressive aspect of
this was that their very best was yet to
be seen the next and final five years of
their production covered possibly the
most popular and anticipated chapter in
the Dragon Balls story the cell saga and
boy did they deliver
[Music]
[Applause]
with each season Dragon Ball Z a bridge
became more and more complex how did you
deal with the increased scope of the
series as it progressed transitioning to
season 3 was actually pretty easy
because it was a natural evolution from
what we were doing already in season 2
which was ok we had these characters now
let's let them breathe yeah let's let
them breathe let's see what they can do
and what they would do in these given
situations we were adapting with what
the tastes were at the time what our
tastes were specifically and just trying
to up our game and pretty much every
level and I know you took on way more
tasks when it came to like cutting
things out of scenes putting things
where they didn't belong in the Cell
Games we got rid of three entire
characters we got raised specifically
you got rid of them yeah I got rid of
Corona prosky and Pisa because we hated
them we added nothing they're the worst
they are the worst they are the worst
edition the anime ever made you heard
that space orphans and bone of the Frog
the space frog the space frog was a
sheep but yeah they were they were not
fun like piroshki corona and peter ruin
satan's joke Saenz whole thing in that
in that art is ruined because of those
characters because they are the worst
versions of his joke and I I hate them I
they ruined his entrance they just take
up time and space
his entire thing is that he's supposed
to be like humanity's pinnacle he is the
fish-out-of-water there yeah that is way
out of his scope trying to pretend he
has his [ __ ] together we have
established these characters and that
was time to write a character based
human because a lot of the humor before
was kind of like oh look at this silly
scene let's separate the scene where now
we were writing of okay now we have
these characters let's play this scene
with those characters and see how it
pans out and it's also where we decided
to actually give some of the people that
didn't have characters a little bit more
time to breathe like TN yo and Yamcha
and chiaotzu who became significantly
snarky er after dying the second time ya
know when he comes back a second time he
is he has died twice and he does not I
absolutely loved writing for chiaotzu in
that in a lot of those scenes we're just
like oh I don't give a [ __ ]
whatever I've died twice your discretion
is advised the one thing you'll notice
is that season three is full of straight
men like all over the place tension
hunts have got a bigger role 17:18
piccolo
you've got all of these characters that
are a lot more down-to-earth it's not
like Napa or Popo or cuckoo help
Gohan steps up to be the hero who was
the hardest to writing hardest to write
for oh and trunks trunks is entire
character in that saga is that he really
wants to be the cool hero and he's just
not he's a failure trunks his whole
thing is that he tries and fails but he
never gives up he wants to be cool he's
a teenager he wants to be accepted by
these people he grew up hearing about
the people he knows as heroes it's like
a kid meeting the Justice League and
wanting to prove himself yeah and then
finding out that the Justice League is
something lower cliffs super incompetent
yeah just either full of [ __ ] or
idiots okay talks
don't be nervous he's just a normal guy
just introduce yourself so your son will
come right damn it I'm son Goku yes
roll with it it was easier and harder in
different ways easier because luckily we
had established these characters and now
they could just bounce off each other
very naturally but harder in that we had
a lot more straight men and serious
moments to deal with
well Frieza looks like you dropped the
ball while having a deep comprehensive
understanding of how the show would play
out from start to finish was indeed a
huge help in the writers room as the
show went on the writing standards for
the series shot higher and higher also
and that very unwavering commitment to
quality meant the show would take longer
to produce with each passing season has
it always taken a long time to write
these episodes what was the quickest
turnover time you've had for one
sometimes it can take a lot longer
though sometimes it goes a lot quicker
sometimes it's a Bojack the turnaround
time after it's been written usually
there's the directing then there's the
editing and the editing process can be
harder or easier depending on the kind
of jokes that we write the length it's
about an 80 hour process after the
actual script and typically when we're
actually you know working on this stuff
there's no break in there either for a
big chunk of season three I can't
remember what the streak was but we were
going for like a year and a half
straight on some of that stuff and it it
wore us down like goddamn Super Saiyan
asks you for a sense of being bald man
you say how many when you burn out on
the creative process
you can't push through that you don't
push through that you have to give space
you have to recoup you have to pull
yourself away because you push yourself
through writer's block
not through burnout for so long I think
it's the pipe dream of ours to say like
hey we're gonna sit down and we're going
to write multiple episodes we're going
to write out a season and we're going to
work on that little by little and
release it on a regular schedule but
that comes with its own big
complications because then you have to
stop everything else in order to do
specifically one thing yeah for a block
period and
it's I mean you got bills to pay man
it's it's hard maintaining a single
projects momentum for over 12 years is a
difficult task for any studio however if
you add constant copyright claims
countless takedowns and the inability to
monetize your work to the list of things
working against you it's not hard to
imagine shows like this being abandoned
after just a few episodes however team
forests are stuck with this show despite
all of these hardships for two main
reasons
a love for the source material and a
desire to entertain and uplift fans like
you and I around the world whether it be
through scenes like quillin's death on
Namek or Vegeta's pink shirts no moment
was too big or too small to inject their
trademark wit and personality you've
mentioned a number of times at various
panels that you don't normally plan
ahead but you do have jokes in mind
sometimes in advance what joke have you
waited the longest to tell you have
heard probably the one that we planned
the furthest ahead and that was the
destruction of the own count Android 18
and krillen I mean we didn't have the
whole joke written out or anything like
that but we knew that that was going to
be the that was going to be the payoff
of the own counter
[Applause]
that was the one that we probably
planned the furthest ahead for when it
comes to actual jokes and there were a
lot in season three that we planned
ahead on that was definitely the one
that we waited the longest on Dragon
Ball Z originally aired in Japan between
1989 and 1996 however the majority of us
western fans would likely have
discovered the show during its initial
international run from 1996 through 2003
when team four star took over the
abridged project six years later in 2008
it's run until 2019 would be only a
couple years shy of the original
broadcast and international runs
combined with a small team of people an
insane amount of passion and love went
into making Dragon Ball Z abridged a
reality a series many of us fans will
surely be revisiting for years to come
do you have any favorite or least
favorite moments from the abridged
series in Lord slug one of my favorite
jokes that we ever did is that Looney
Tunes moment where piccolo is fighting
dota Davo and like breaks his arm kicks
them off the rooftop we just do this
Looney Tunes thing where it keeps going
back up get knocked back down oh wait
don't here catch him off guard hey how's
it going this is one that always comes
back to me as a line that I personally
really liked and have resonated great
with the audience which was drugs you
couldn't fathom the amount of dead men
behind me some of our actual favorite
moments from the series as you know
people that made it are some of those
more serious moments that do resonate
very well tackling Gohan going Super
Saiyan 2 redoing the entire score for
that which I pushed I pushed for you
push for a very long time yeah I and I
was like we're going to I'm gonna get a
reward I'm gonna get a new singer it's
gonna be in English it's gonna be
[ __ ] crazy
[Music]
yeah actually I thought of another
favorite oh and this is one that like
it's just I was just very proud of us
when we did it because when we were
watching through the scene itself we
noticed that they implemented the
Wilhelm scream oh it had nothing to do
with any actual characters it was just
to freeze the soldiers talking back and
forth doesn't it sound like nah dude
it's more like I just thought that like
that was one of my proudest comedic
moments as for least favorite if I had
to go with one specifically it might be
the swapping of Raddatz his actor
fighting over the microphone thing
actually I have one the nightmare scene
that bullet has a oh yeah I regret how
we wrote that scene because it was
unnecessarily dark and it was back
during a time where that sort of dark
humor it was all the rage yes I'm not
here for the Dragon Ball spread um
it's weird how humor and comedy things
change so rapidly and so quickly and the
atmosphere the the ecosystem that which
within you work it's so difficult to
keep up with it it is a challenge in the
day-to-day and it's not one that I'm
like to complain about because he'll
everybody's got that problem all
creatives have that problem but it is
definitely keeps you on your toes I
think it's probably been a thing that
kind of helps though just like the long
form of how we've been how we worked
with the show is just like as we went on
we did adapt and we did change it's hard
to say we objectively got better but I
would definitely you know it stands to
reason to say that over time we improved
our writing or editing our acting
everything got better as time went on
and I don't think I literally don't
believe that we would have done that if
we weren't challenged if we didn't want
so desperately to keep things fresh
compelling characters are the heart of
any narrative and so team four star was
given the task of taking dragonballs
expansive cast most of whom many of us
have known since childhood and molding
them into a caricatured version of
themselves all the while maintaining
their recognizable personalities for the
most part in the abridged series you've
written characters like Vegeta Goku and
Frieza as exaggerated versions of the
original characters but cells seems to
be doing his own thing entirely how did
you approach writing him paka in the
writing room when it comes to characters
that are voiced by one of the writers
that writer will be way more prominence
in coming up with some of the stuff
where that character now as cell went on
as he became like you know perfect cell
imperfect cell was taka doing his best
to make the most weird disturbing but
incredibly like just like deranged I
believe at the time he said he wanted to
be a cross between that way she was
beetlejuice and wishmaster
yeah that kind of a character where it's
like okay I'm gonna I'm gonna get you
but I'm gonna have fun while I'm doing
it I'm here - I'm here to flex Anya
introduction is one of my favorite
scenes from that
like Bar None that's oh no my favorite
scene actually this scene may be my
favorite scene that I've ever worked on
is when TJ and the wombat Wahlberg doing
their radio show and corresponding with
their show you have cell wandering
around eating people and you don't see
him on screen you constantly see him
just off screen his shadow you never
actually see him for the most part and
as it goes on the town becomes a ghost
town and then at the very last second he
like radio studio video killed the radio
star plays in the background and then
the last thing you hear is the song play
before it cuts to black and I you had a
lot of fun editing that scene and we had
a lot of fun coming up with and writing
because that was like that was the most
different scene I think we ever did yeah
for at least that season maybe for the
whole show just because it allowed us to
be way more creative than anything we
had done previously yeah and I remember
we were like okay how do we make this
scene work if there's no dialogue and
then we were like we're debating cutting
that in the Nikki town scene but the
scene preceding it was cell talking to
himself was just good hey Jerry
what's your name named Sal and you were
looking fine imperfect cell specifically
it was easily the creepiest character we
worked with if only because he is
literally a monster that eats people we
wanted to make a character that was
highly unsettling and yet could be very
funny and that's why you have scenes
where he's talking to himself
yelling yelling at the bus driver who's
honking Adam after he whips his head 180
degrees around with us like playing
Jeepers Creepers because we were making
a Jeepers Creepers to reference there
[Music]
it was a very fun character to work with
because he's such a different villain
early on eventually he just kind of
becomes Frieza meets a saying like his
prominence characteristics shift
dramatically towards Frieza and Vegeta
at the more perfect side of his life
cycle of course semi-perfect so is one
of those he was yeah he's like that
weird puberty stage even in the original
version is a little he's possessive
he's domineering he's cocksure he knows
he's not perfect so this is what lips
feel like that character is sort of
interesting because he kind of looks and
sounds like an idiot but we also wrote
some scenes where he's legitimately
intimidating
[Music]
and then when perfect salt came along it
was really just okay now he's I don't
hear what they have about em you
[ __ ]
he's in control he loves what he's doing
and he just wants to have the best fight
he can because of the Goku in him what
do you think of our glorious
battleground all right I'm a small innit
I prefer intimate we wrote to him and
Goku in that are to be fight sexual the
treat fighting like [ __ ] that's their
whole thing they love the art of
fighting and they treat it like the most
intimate relationship they could
possibly be
which is why we win Goku switches Africa
he's like no you knew what this was just
a fight nothing more you [ __ ] while
Goku in cells conflicting personalities
played well with their mutual love for
fighting the true highlight of the cell
saga would undoubtedly be the titular
characters clash with the young son
gohan with his super saiyan 2
transformation being a fan favorite many
of whom Helia as the best moment the
original series produced both hype and
expectations among viewers was
understandably high however just before
the climactic battle would commence the
show seemingly vanished what exactly
brought on the hiatus and how did that
affect the writing of the last episodes
how far in advance was the highest
planned if at all I can't really say
that the hiatus was planned so much part
of it was due to burnout we'd worked
very very hard on that season we had
been more involved with the show during
that arc and I feel like we've ever been
before because something you'll notice
the editing for season 3 is a step above
season 2 just as season 2 is a step
above season 1 we started getting actual
like new lip flaps for characters new
art new assets new animation it was so
much more involved they were longer
episodes we were taking more and more
care to make sure that they were getting
new music everything
we were trying to make season 3 as good
as we possibly could and at some point
man we just it hit us hard that we
needed some time to relax and and take a
step back and prepare for what was going
to be a three-part super long finale but
another reason was that we had actually
moved to a new studio we had gotten a
new scene you know we were really kind
of trying to refocus ourselves one of
the things that we realized was hey
sooner or later
Dragon Ball Z abridged is gonna and it
would no matter what happened we had a
finite amount of episodes yeah and we
needed to prepare for that because
here's the thing we had Let's Plays and
we had some small reviews and we had and
as things went on I mean Let's Plays on
YouTube have dipped significantly over
time anyway
yeah we had to make a decision we had to
figure out what is the life of team four
star Beyond Dragon Ball Z abridge and
furthermore what can we actually make
money like yeah so we had to make the
decision to take a step back from Dragon
Ball Z abridged and give it some air and
focus on new projects and you know I I
will definitely apologize for making
people wait because you know obviously I
don't like making people wait on
material I didn't want to wait on
material I I mean we know full well what
people subscribed for yeah we know we
aren't ignorant to that as many people
might think we are yeah we understand
but but I will never and I'll say this
outright I will never apologize for
planning our future and working hard
work because there are many wonderful
people who work at this company myself
not included and I would like to make
sure that all of them have the
opportunity to do the things that they
love for a living it's really not
uncommon for passion to conflict with
responsibility over the course of a
projects lifespan creating what you love
may fill your heart but oftentimes not
your stomach and DBZ a being a
non-profit fan made parody made the gap
between creative desire and fine
necessity all the greater still however
team four-star were steadfast in their
commitment to the completion of season
three and having honed their writing
chops over the first two seasons they
were confident in their ability to add a
dramatic flair to the five-year long
endeavor in season three you are much
more willing to explore serious scenes
play them straight and even write your
own was this the theme from the get-go
with season three or did it just sort of
happen I won't lie when we were writing
out the scene with Goku leaving we
actually had to make the decision of
whether or not he was going to say I
love you and we cut that because it felt
it doesn't feel Goku no it didn't but
one of the things that I definitely
wanted in there and this this line for
some reason meant so much to me what and
the line was I'm proud of you son well
yeah that's me yeah that's your that's
your line my line was actually that year
we spend the chamber was the greatest
year of my life
well that was supposed to be Goku say at
that time I spent with you that was so
important to me that is Goku's way of
saying I know we don't know we see eye
to eye on what the things that we enjoy
but that made me very happy by sight
that theme of fatherhood that uh knowing
that your father might be an imperfect
person and just being a kid and hearing
those things and also the dramatic irony
of by son but that was the one that was
like my big sticking points like we've
made this a running joke by son has been
a running joke it needs to be the
emotional capper of this scene which is
so us
actually to take a joke and then make a
dramatic moment and hey if we do make it
out of this please pick up my head and
beat your father to death with Gohan
going super saiyan - I think was the one
that we put the most like this this is
the moment that we are going to play as
like as straitlaced as possible this is
fan wanker II this is us doing a love
letter to Dragon Ball Z which
essentially is what like the entire
latter half of season 3 was for us was
just us trying to show how much we
absolutely love this proto like this
product I mean yeah it's true if I had
to say anything season 3 is our love
letter top to bottom actually speaking
of love letters during the credits at
the very end there is a scene of 16
underneath a tree with a music box
version of lumineux he playing android
16 and I want to I want to put emphasis
on this character was not a character I
expected to love writing for when we
started by the end of the saga Android
16 became my favorite character in that
arc maybe the show and it meant the
world to me that he had a happy ending
because he never got that in the
original he didn't get any kind of like
he goes out with a tragic death that
ultimately has no automatic relevance
afterward it just kind of like nothing
ever comes back with it it's there's no
narrative follow through he dies and
then he doesn't get back because
apparently he doesn't have a soul it's
kind of ironic that he can be kind of
the emotional core to a lot of those
Android scenes where you know they're
just kind of focused on having fun and
doing whatever they want because this is
the first time they've had freedom
in like since they've been Bladerunner
so they just want to go out and do what
they want when they want to do it and
they're just bringing 16 along because
he hasn't objective it's like okay we'll
go do what you want to do and we'll do
what we want to do doing it he ends up
being kind of their moral compass in a
lot of ways which is really I think what
kind of changed the timeline yeah I
think the reason that Android 17 and 18
are different characters in that
timeline is because 16 was there this
cannot get any dumber agreed sure is a
lot of not killing Goku going on right
now a deep understanding of the source
material couldn't be clearer from some
of the additions team for star made to
the original script any long-running
franchise will have its peaks and
valleys and fans know better than anyone
what the community responded to and what
they didn't despite the show starting
out as a straight-up comedy like
countless other abridged series that
came before them as the years went by
Kaiser Lani and taka began to see an
opportunity to defy expectations to
catch viewers off-guard and to give
Dragon Ball Z the respect they knew it
deserved it's much easier to make
someone laugh than it is to make them
cry how did you approach the more
dramatic scenes like Goku and Gohan in
episode 60 if we were to expand any
further on the idea of how we really
approached that it's it mostly comes
down to our own personal psychologies at
that point in our own life experiences
because you write what you know to a
certain extent like we all have our own
relationships with our fathers and we
all believe in a certain ideal of
fatherhood and but we also understand
that people are imperfect and part of
growing up is realizing that your
parents don't have anything like have
about as much figured out as you do it
when you hit that point in life yeah and
that's a frightening and startling
realization for a lot of people so Goku
being able to admit to Gohan who at this
point in our series has been looking at
him like this slack-jawed idiot who's
irresponsible who doesn't know what he's
doing and for Goku to be able to like
admit to him I'm bad at this stuff I'm
good at fighting I know how to do that
it's what I like doing I didn't realize
that you didn't
in many ways apologizing for not
recognizing these features in his son
but letting him know how proud he is of
the person that he has become and will
continue to grow to be I'm sorry
fighting is what makes me happy and I
just thought it would make you happy too
I think when you're writing for a scene
that is supposed to make people cry
first thing you have to do is establish
a true emotional a human connection
between they're the two of the
characters or at the character in the
audience more so be real yeah when I
write for these scenes one of the things
that I go for is stark raw emotion with
piccolo and Comi Comi breaks at a point
he breaks when he says well maybe I'd
rather be dead instead of part of you
why does he say that does he hate
piccolo no he does because it's because
they were the same person and he hates
hates that part of himself but we all
have a part of ourselves that we hate
that we wish we could get rid of but he
also notes that he's been stuck in the
same place for a long time he notes that
this was a prison this place is a prison
for me I am stuck here like he even
mentions all the things that happened
down there I can't do anything about
because I can't believe and then he
mentions to piccolo if I put myself
inside of you all I've done is trade one
prison for another and that's that's a
little peek into what was commies life
like no the only chance I have left is
giving up my free will to someone else
it's just another prison and then when
it comes to the Android 16 scene when I
wrote that scene that scene was supposed
to be about a young man who loves his
father and trying to communicate with
him you know manner of speaking trying
to follow in his footsteps as his dad
was part of the red ribbon army is like
oh hey I'm gonna you know do your proud
dad yeah I might not be like you know as
smart as you are but I'm gonna I'm gonna
go out there and do my job for this
thing that you believe in and that's why
I doing that video call that he has with
his father i sat down with Joshua remix
and I really told them okay this
delivery has to be as human as possible
there's no joke in this scene it's just
a young man talking with his father
shooting him a message yeah you know
with a [ __ ] bird in the background
and then when it came to the scene with
Gohan and Goku it it was just all about
this is the moment where Goku connects
full-on connects with his son tells him
exactly what he needs to tell him in
that moment and more so it's about
payoff all these jokes that we've made
about Goku being at bad dad it's time to
like pay those off in the way that you
know he might have been from a certain
point of view but he didn't mean to be
he wasn't trying to be a bad dad yeah he
just wasn't good at it it's something
that he wasn't built for we had gotten a
lot of and I believe do criticism for
how we handle the whole father like Goku
being a bad father thing we leaned too
heavily early on because that was the
joke with the fandom and that's
something I've talked about where in the
first season we were leaning into jokes
that were already established because we
are we didn't think about making our own
like versions of these characters and
playing that out straight we just
thought oh yeah you know cookies bad bad
memes and a bunch of [ __ ]
but if we hadn't leaned into that we
wouldn't have had as strong of a payoff
with that scene like I don't regret
making the kind of jokes that we made
first of all because like you said those
were like that was the culture at the
time and still kind of is now people are
kind of coming back around to it yeah
people are finally accepting that Goku
it's not a terrible father he's just not
conventional and he struggles with it
he's an anime dad yeah he still loves
his son he loves his wife he loves his
family and will protect them he just
happens to be dead and gone a lot yeah
and that pretty much wraps things up
67 episodes 11 movies 3 specials over 16
hours worth of content in 3 entire
seasons over 12 long years I think
saying goodbye to something you've grown
up with is almost always a bitter pill
to swallow Dragon Ball Z abridged
appeared during a period of time when
Dragon Ball itself was almost completely
absent from the mainstream zeitgeist a
fan made parody that United old and new
fans alike long before the likes of
Dragon Ball Kai and Dragon Ball super
hit the airwaves it wasn't ever
encouraged by any official production in
the West or in the East it was barely
even supported on YouTube and more often
than not it was an uphill battle for
them but for 12 years they made this
incredibly silly wonderful and heartfelt
show for us all to enjoy so as hard as
it is to say goodbye I'll leave you with
this Thank You team four star you were
hilarious and we quoted everything you
said I'm just not afraid of change I yes
I've never been when it comes down to it
I know they're gonna be alright because
if I've learned anything since landing
on earth it's that everyone is stronger
than they think they are I left behind
the best people in the world and I'm
happy about that
things changed and they're gonna keep
changing there ain't no stopping math
most importantly now they can live their
own lives and make their own futures I
can't wait to see the kind of future
they make what I'd like to extend a
special thank yous a team for staff for
being so open and eager to participate
in this project I would also like to
thank Tom Regan another youtuber who
creates incredible and hilarious video
game breakdowns without his help on this
it almost certainly wouldn't have
happened in the style that it did or on
time you can check out Tom's channel
here and if you haven't seen the other
parts of this series check out part one
and team 4 stars channel by clicking the
prompt on screen now but that will do
for this week thank you so much for
watching
[Music]